titanfall - I've been dying to talk
about this since our review went up Rob
you and I play a lot of it you were at
the review event with me down in
Hollywood yeah ma'am you and I both
seemed really positive by this game I
gave it a 9 out of 10 I think it's an
awesome sequel I think it's a really fun
shooter I think respawn nailed it
what do you think I think your score
concurs man that's your opinion yeah I
think it's it's easily one of the best
games for me as far as year goes like
top game for sure if not the top like
battlefield 1 and title 2 or like neck
and neck as far as like enjoyability and
like the doom even did some work on me
like I love that game too but this game
is something else where just to start
off just the movement in general like
it's addicting like I constantly want to
move in this world may it be
single-player or multiplayer it's just
so fun to play yeah we talked about this
last episode but if you're a shooter fan
this year is not like doing you any harm
there's overwatch there - there's battle
born if that was your cup of tea there's
Gears of War 4 there's Battlefield 3 is
called duty coming out over the doing
some interesting things yeah and then
titanfall 2 now I absolutely love this
game I think in terms of being a sequel
I you know like we talked to respawn
this summer and they told us what their
intent was but to me it really does feel
like it is the game that they probably
wanted to make back if they had the
numbers back in when they formed respawn
and when they released a game in 2013
for the Xbox one I think in terms of
being a sequel it seems like the changes
are minor at first right it's these six
new Titans which are kind of a more hero
units in themselves more there's more
character to them they're not these
three variants like light medium heavy
they're not like they have their own set
load outs you can change them a little
bit but for all intents burgers are
almost like superheroes there's you see
I on right here with like the laser
attacks and then you'll see scorch with
the flame attacks you'll see tone who's
more explosives and they all have these
little quirks that kind of the more you
play the more will come out and that
reminds me of hero shooters or MOBAs
right you're learning these people you
know I hate the phrase is overused all
the time but this game is really easy to
learn but as difficult to master and
start like being really good at it
obviously there's two layers between the
pilots and the Titans for those
unfamiliar the first game
pilots like it still is the game to be
in terms of movement I know like black
ops 3 is done an advanced warfare had
its own movie system called duty
infinite warfare is doing something
similar overwatch had some characters I
could wall run in vault in double jump
but here like you said it still just
feels unreal it feels really good and
now that I'm playing like Battlefield
which of course is a slower game and I
love that game but any time I play
anything else now I'm just kind of
getting like antsy I want to like ground
slide do a double jump to the wall and
then vault over something and yeah
and in both the campaign and multiplayer
the mobility factor of chaining wall
runs and jumps and stuff like that is
really rewarding and I think in actually
like 2 different ways like multiplayer I
guess both games when you are chaining
these wall runs you're gaining speed so
when you consider a game mode like
capture the flag or you can then combo
it with stim which just gives you a
freaking just a rush of energy and speed
you just can fly across a map depending
on on your ability to to utilize that
traversal aspects and you can score
flags and if you're good at that then
you are just a valuable runner and then
you know we were talking about a handful
about
single-player the game even says it like
when you die this is not a
duck-and-cover shooter like when you're
playing on a higher difficulty you are
it says in a death screen menu who says
when you are wall running you are
gaining momentum you're gaining speed
and that makes you a harder target to
hit for enemy III so you are just
looking at every map in this game and
single-player especially at each level
and you're just trying to find you know
just predictable routes so how do I get
out of this sticky situation you're
given enemies grunts to have these crazy
shields the only way to basically kill
them is to get behind them so then
you're convoying your your cloak to
basically get that wall run and get
behind them so they don't see you there
and then you get your your kill on that
guy it's just there's so much creativity
and how you play that I'm literally
playing this campaign again like for the
third time it's just so fun to play yeah
and people are giving it [ __ ] just
because it's like four or five hours and
it it is on the short side you and I
were talking about you should definitely
play if you're pretty experienced with
shooters I played on hardened like the
third up third tier up and I
still only died like five six times
maybe throughout the four and a half
five hour campaign the campaign doesn't
feel tacked on though I feel like they
put a lot of work into it despite its
length I didn't like the writing at all
you like Pete you played the first few
minutes and that really that interesting
like a pilot in his Titan as that was
really ham fisted is valuable soldier on
the battlefield with the cigar in his
mouth yeah like you guys have talked
about some stuff that sounds really
interesting like between Titan and pilot
they had a sort of relationship that
develops that sounds kinda interesting
to me I still haven't got that far yet
the bright spots in the plot and the
writing are but definitely between your
Titan bt7 274 who has a personality he's
a sentient thing but he also despite how
smart he is he doesn't understand human
phrases so Jack Cooper to make care to
be like I missed or you missed me or
something or did you miss me he's like I
wasn't shooting at you there'd be a
violation of my protocol or something
how can I miss you and he's like never
mind and those ever mahan get funny but
I feel like the writing realized too
much on that and then the villains
themselves are the most outlandish just
villains into it but it's still there
were other parts where the campaign was
trying to be really serious and like
what are you going for with this
narrative but in terms of design
speaking of those villains they're like
boss fights and then the missions are
constantly changing up how it's using
the pilot movement the pilot combat how
the Titan combi has figured into it you
see BTS throwing you right here really
good platforming throughout the game
this section kind of becomes more of a
puzzle platformer we're almost mixed to
the shooter and there's one mission that
I wish we could talk about you were
talking about flanking guys and like
kind of manipulating your environment I
really wish we could talk about more
people play it's like 3/4 the way
through the campaign but it says
mechanic that comes out of nowhere and
you're like what is this doing and then
you start to slowly understand it my
point being I don't want to spoil that
the campaign is paced really well you'll
get into these like midair ship battles
were jumping from ship to ship your
Titan will factor into it your Titan
itself bTW unlike the Titans from
multiplayer you could switch on the fly
once you collect them you can't go back
and replay the campaign with all the
loadouts which sucks you still get them
at certain intervals certain spots in
each mission but you just press right on
the d-pad you switch to scorch depending
the situation there's a kind of a like a
reaction like a dynamism that you don't
have a multiplayer because you can't
walk into a firefight be like
[ __ ] Northstar the sniper would be
better for the situation rather than
Legion the minigun wheeling one that
became really fun especially during boss
fights I think I killed one boss using
four different Titans which is loadout
sorry same Titan but don't load up and
sometimes it really requires it like
especially on a harder difficulty I
found certain bosses you have to predict
right a scorch for instance a horse boss
would like you know coat the area with
fire maybe I should step back and use a
Northstar type and snipe him and then
you'll get a different you know SS man
and then you grow accustomed to that
tactic right but then the next level or
match your face with another Titan who's
doing the exact opposite so you're
forced to like switcher loadouts and
yeah again like on-the-fly
many of times you're just throwing a
situation like you know a North Star is
another good example of someone who
doesn't have like any defense so then
you're you're switching around and
you're throwing a tone shield down in
order to snipe through like it's just
you're going back and forth in a very
like up paced manner that's keeping you
like really engaged and thinking ahead
yeah yeah and despite the fact that you
can't switch load us on the fly in
multiplayer unless you're like
respawning or whatever there is a
certain visual vocabulary to this now
it's almost like I keep talking about
MOBAs or hero shooters
I interviewed Vince Zampella back at e3
as a CEO of respawn used to be like
called infinity warden wada he was
saying there actually looked at fighting
games in terms of how you want to fight
like obviously it's gonna be very
different but like with overwatch you
recognize that that's Azaria coming
around the corner you should probably be
ready for her graviton surge or
something you've learned that Titans not
just to know how to attack with them but
also how to counter them and how to
exploit their weaknesses which is a huge
deal in this game and that's what I
really love about these Titans if you
see you'll recognize scorch if you don't
recognize his body itself which is very
distinct from the others he's not skinny
he's this big huge dude with a like a
like a kind of oil tank on his back he
almost looks like a Bioshock big dad
totally this actually wasn't gonna say
the other day when I saw him but then
you have North Star who's skinny but has
this he's like four prongs jetpack
coming off and you immediately recognize
that if it's yeah if it's a scorch and
like if you're Ronin and you have a
sword you should probably get up close
to scorch before he can coat the area in
flames to kind of push you away
you're scorch and you see a North Star
you should probably try to get behind
cover and lob your artillery over these
things instead but that's what I really
love about this multiplayer it seems
like a minor change just switch up the
classes but it results me like ripple
effects that kind of like create this
really kind of like cool gameplay loop
between not just like between pilot and
Titan but also just the Titans
themselves and speaking of the MOBA
element I think that's so strong in the
game type last Titan standing really
just you know 5 e5 people are so
cautious they're like and you get that
same element to of like you see
everyone's choice for Titan you all
can't be Ronan's you're gonna get
crushed some like someone can counter
that but you know as rounds progressed
you can kind of move around but you want
that tone who can throw down basically a
shield for everyone to use in lanes you
want someone to basically sneak around
and flank like a ronin like you kind of
like can work around that and it gets
really competitive that mode and that's
a mode that I never really that was in
the first game right I believe it was
ending yeah yeah yeah of course and I
never really played that you know
attrition and you know another one and
you even bounty hunt is another bounty
how it's great yeah bounty hunt to paint
a picture it's your each time you kill
grunts so there's not AI in every mode I
know people were worried about that
people who didn't like the AI if you're
just playing skirmish there's no grunts
it's just pilots and Titans
there's pilot versus pilot mode now just
like the movement the more Call of Duty
ish combat but bounty hunt is great
because and this is one of those modes
that like kind of like makes you
reconsider how to play the game you gain
money by killing grounds and other
pilots and Titans but then you can save
it up if someone kills you they get half
your money into there like a wallet or
whatever but then at a certain point the
match at the end of each wave of grunts
three or four banks will open up and
everybody's rushing to deposit you have
to hold X and your money will drain so
you're not automatically going to put
all your money into it so hey you have
to get out your Titan to do that you
can't you have to be a pilot so it's the
best part about the whole because there
will be other pilots who are jerks like
me who will camp out and watch these
banks and wait for pilots just come in
and deposit like 750 bucks and get half
of whatever that is for killing them and
write your deposit my own if you didn't
make any money that's your goal now is
to prevent people from doing that yeah
and also there's what's the other one
yeah like pilot versus pilot feels great
but I mean I'm like watching this
footage to go back to what I loved about
this game the first titanfall people got
burnt out and I know like they were
trying to figure out how they could kind
of give it more vitality longevity in
the long run and you it's not always
cranked up to 11 they're these calm
moments where you're like making a plan
and trying to figure out what to do next
and the maps are pretty wide open this
time around first one had some bigger
maps but these in general or you know
facilitate both pilot and Titan combat
but you keep playing and the more I play
the more I learn like route on the the
who's kind of like a Call of Duty ish
Titan you know he's got this regular
marksmen explosive rifle and shoulder
mounted missiles but you have to instead
of just like hovering your reticle over
someone to lock-on you have to actually
attack them so I think it's the base one
is you have to hit them three times with
your gun but then you find out that this
sonar thing you could shoot also
automatically gets you one tick toward
locking on to shoot your missiles and
then I on Rob neither you nor I knew
that all of that has like her attacks
the Titans are she will feed into one
central power core so if you're just
firing your guns alternate fire that's
taking away from what you could be using
with your shoulder mounted laser and
then obviously to a cool-down but you
have to manage and there are these weird
little wrinkles with each Titan that
actually kind of make you play a certain
way and then obviously North Star being
with the glass can and if you hover it's
kind of like Farah from overwatch you
can hover and shoot missiles downward at
Titans or pilots alike there is a
certain amount of trepidation when
you're about to because I could get
really [ __ ] up if there's a three
North Star in the other side of the map
about to shoot me mm-hmm
and then you have Ronin like these
little like you know each Titan can add
an extra dash to their loadout yeah
Ronin starts with two so if you add that
third - and then you have the phase
shift which is when Ronin goes it's like
another reality that appears like
somewhere like 30 feet away I came
around the corner and last Titan
standing and I saw North Star at the
other end I'm like [ __ ] I dodged to the
right adesh to the left that like dashed
again and then I used phase work but I
was right next that would've been
possible if I didn't change my loadout
like that right that's not something I
would consider until I actually like
played a lot of Ronin and that's what I
think is also really nice is because
that you're getting those hero shooter
elements of recognizing a an enemy and
knowing how to handle it
however you
still get that customizable aspect to
meet your play style so for Ronan yes
you have high mobility well you know
what I'm gonna go all out I'm gonna add
that other the other - and I'm gonna
focus on basically getting to someone
quick enough or Norstar you know
extremely weak no defense I can add
another tether to slow people down but
you know what I'm just gonna go all out
and just you know make her a bit more
powerful Titan so yeah that's really fun
and experiment with some of these and
some of these are like really like what
come off is really big game changers
like give 20% more to your core ability
right so if you have a favorite core
ability damn you're getting that much
quicker and it's just more effective I
don't know I just I can't wait to and
and that's where I hope to see the
longevity of the game is like getting
these unlocks later on and then being
able to like master them down the road
obviously there are other gimmicks that
are appealing like skins and such like
there's something about putting some
sick-ass teeth yeah it's like some of
them are just like no teeth that go up
past your ear like if I was a North Star
hovering over you you see that I I'd
what myself and that's like it kind of
speaks to how attached you get these
Titans that you actually care about the
aesthetic stuff like like I don't know
like overwatch another example all the
unlocks in overwatch are aesthetic and
that's because I think you care about
these characters but yeah and then I
mean like you just mentioned they have a
progression system now as opposed to the
just the burn cards in the first game
and it's pretty steady for me you and I
played I think I played about 20 a few
more than 20 hours total of multiplayer
between the review event and this past
week before when live servers should go
back up Thursday you know when it
releases way out east and we'll get to
play more I'm really excited - yeah and
just tap on again they did a nice thing
with the burn cards I was never a huge
fan of those burn cards because you're
just given so many yet such such a high
rate there's any one of fan I don't know
I mean I guess burn cards in general no
one I mean I'm a big fan of them but but
the amount of cards you're getting it
was hard to manage and you found
yourself going through mobile I feel
like they did a nice thing of basically
taking you know the burn cards and
putting them into the pilot boost so as
you progress they know once you get to
level 50 you can get these
really cool ones like I have to say a
traceurs time warp back you know II mean
like you're getting these abilities
later on that you want to get to and
what seems to be a nice ways away which
is which makes the game yeah I mean
hopefully long term for people
definitely it's also cool like mixing
and matching the pilot loadout to put
Titans like this pilot like having cloak
and also there's that Titan ability
where you eject when it's about to
explode you'll automatically cloak so
people can't just immediately pick the
other one out of the air like you did to
me earlier on this segment I was
laughing because while you were talking
behind you I saw the footage you smoking
at North Star but anyway yeah that's
titanfall to the review is up on site I
gave it a 9 out of 10 I really like this
game battlefield 1 is great Call of Duty
I'm curious about but I would encourage
you not to ignore titanfall 2 it
releases October 28th on ps4 Xbox one
and PC